That's kind of the cool thing about
Porsche, Porsche builds cars because they
believe that or because we believe that
they are the best things that
you can build and in the end there is
the world around it that also
sees it that way and that  understands that and in the
end these are so the car is
the focus and that's also the case with Fett
e.g. the car is the focus or
is the centerpiece but the party and
the surroundings bring the le Dr so
what makes it really cool  The
people around you are welcome
to the OMR podcast. I'll keep the introduction
short today because the name will
already tell you something. The guest is fery Porsche
hi fery servus I'll start straight away like that
because that's what I noticed on the
way here to our meeting
Think about it, there are hardly any German people
who are known, who have a family name
that is such a global brand. Who
else
came up with that? That's a good question. They really do
n't come up like that, so
Rossmann, for example, I thought so,
but that's a more national thing
or maybe  still in Austria and
Switzerland or then somehow with
Mr. Würt, I noticed that of course
you know him, there are a
lot of Würz or with Mr. Kuhne,
you don't somehow think of
this Mr. Kühne and that's how I got
through it  I went through the list and then I
noticed, okay, Volkswagen, there's
no one there who's called that,
or at BMW there's no one who's called that. At Mercedes, there's
no one who has a Benz  occurred to me and then
of course I asked myself and
the question is probably the
question of your life
is it good or bad I think it
has both a bit um in I
would say so in in kindergarten
elementary school at the very beginning makes
game makes it  no difference, yes,
you don't notice it at all, you do
n't notice it that way and your
environment somehow does
n't attach any value to it yet, you really notice
that it's something special somehow
or that people somehow start to listen up. That's
when it starts  So in high school
and to be honest it's still
a time where you actually
want to belong and not
stand out in any way, um and so
I would say that maybe at the
beginning I think it was a
pretty good school because there  Did you then
notice how you had to deal with it
and so on and I decided relatively quickly
that I'm going to pay more attention to my
first name and just
be the Ferd and
leave it out a bit because I think
in the end they'll find it  Most people
have a positive connotation to it,
yes, it's a great car, it's a cool
brand, so actually most people do
n't mean you any harm but rather find it
cool and exciting, um and yes,
I would say on the whole
it's something positive but it  Of course,
somehow it comes with a responsibility and,
um, gag, you ca
n't actually make many mistakes now, because it
always seems like that to me straight away and everything is under the microscope, no, for
example, now you're lying completely
drunk in front of some club.
Maybe you shouldn't do that now,
happens Z  As a teenager sometimes, but
yes there are definitely two things
where you should be more careful
or where I have my
background or my family
in my head, yes,
but I don't have the feeling that
that limits me  in Daily Life I
think that's the thing, if it
were just Germany and I
actually know that from a few German
influencers that I
know who then say, well then
I'll just fly to London or
to Dubai and there I am  just nobody
and I can do whatever I want
and there is nobody at the
hotel reception who
looks up somehow but you told me you
just came from Dubai and that's exactly how it will
be when you check in then it
will be okay there too
Mr. the lady said okay
who so yes of course I always get the question
as soon as the or often but
now you have to say a I'm
not now so people don't recognize me
on the street now at least just the
party or just the one the ice cream is awesome
find or so it's happened
twice now but on the whole
I can still
go through life relatively incognito. You're a bit of an
influencer now, in fact
I have the Instagram 25,000 followers
and it's already an account that
's somehow public at least
Yes, I think with IC Race and FAT and
also with my architecture I have
a lot of things that I
want to talk about somehow and I see it more as an
opportunity
to place my topics there and to be
honest that's what happened  a bit
devoted but I'm actually quite
happy with it and I think it's a really
cool platform and to be
honest I also think it's cool
to use it. I mean if you can now
see on Instagram who I
follow who also follows you, that's how
it is  Yes, generally like that and that's where I
saw Daniel archam so top
designers now from today's
generation Ronnie feig or people like
that who are now on our stage
as superstars I was all
over them oh look at the consequences all fery
Porsche like that  In that respect, I think they
accept you as a designer
and I just told you that you are a trained
architect. Maybe tell me your
story in general, so you came
from high school in Austria, no,
I grew up in Munich, I went
to a normal
high school in Munich where I  I'm also really grateful to my parents
that they didn't send me to a
private school, but that
I somehow had the opportunity there, so I just
grew up quite normally, and I
still have my friends from there
and I think that helped me in my
career in some way
no contact, so it sounds so
stupid now, yes, but that I grew up quite normally there
and then I
thought about what I'm studying. Now I
did a few internships, so to speak, a
gapier which I filled with an
internship at
EADS and then at  at David Chipperfield
and got a taste of different areas
and honestly found
architecture somehow the coolest, found
the working environment cool to sit there in the office,
thought the models for farmers were
cool, thought he was somehow
good as a guy like reingek, so he has three
offices on the  all over the world and David
Chfield, yes, one of the
most successful, well-known architects
in the world, yes, and he comes in
there and you have team meetings
and, um, I just found it extremely
impressive how he checks the project in two minutes,
um, and with five  Sentences
can actually rebuild everything and
know exactly okay where to start and and and
the project really improves in
5 minutes um and that kind of
excited me and I thought two points about
architecture were cool once um that
I that you're like that
After that you have a skill so that it's
somehow clear to you what are you studying
after that um and I thought the combination
of technical and creative was cool
and that's why I
decided to study it and
went to Vienna um and yes but actually
yours  Family at least your father
grew up in Zellamsee or my
father grew up in Zellamsee and Stuttgart,
yes, okay, plays a big
role in the family, so it's
Austrian roots, they're
relevant in some way, yes, my great-grandpa, my
grandpa, they're all
in  I grew up in Austria, so
my great-grandpa was born in what is now the Czech Republic,
Bohemia, and my grandpa was
born in Wienerneustadt and my father
was born in Stuttgart but
went to school in Zellamsee or
at least primary school, so Zell is
somehow the second home for
all of us and I  I learned to ski a lot,
so I spent all my holidays there
or spent a lot of holidays there
and my cell feels
a lot like home, so let's explain
a little bit about the
structure of the family because I think
you know from the outside now  Above all,
to assign your father who is
now, so to speak, Wolfgang Porsche,
I think he is currently a member of the
board at VW. I think he is
also the head of the supervisory board at Porsche and I think he is also the head of the supervisory board
at the holding company that
holds the majority of VW, that is
correct, yes, correct  My father is
chairman of the Porsche board, chairman of the supervisory board of the
PSE, and a
normal member of the
supervisory board of Audi and Volkswagen, and in reality
we have two family representatives, we
have two family lines, so to speak, the
P and the  Porsches and both have a
speaker and that's my father and his
cousin okay okay and say then the
founder of all of this is your
great-grandfather no, it depends where
you start so the founder of Porsche
is my grandpa
um and my great-grandpa has his
I had my own design office, was
once employed at Daimler, so at Aust Daimler
but also at Daimler in Stuttgart and
then built the Beetle, so somehow
the founder of Volkswagen also
okay that's
great and your grandpa is the founder of Porsche
okay and let's say you still have it
met my grandpa, yes, my great-grandpa,
not my grandpa, I met him, he
gave me my first bike
and I have really cool memories
lying on the carpet with him at Christmas
and, funnily enough, playing with
small model cars and I was
six when he died
Unfortunately that doesn't mean there was a real conversation
like I would
like to do now.
There are iconic people in Germany with the founding story, so it's
really legendary, so it's one of the few
absolute German global brands,
actually no, so what my
parents have to say is a really cool one  Guy must have
been like that and I think very
calm and thoughtful and
yes, it's definitely
kind of a crass story, especially
because you have to think about it
after the war,
it's not like that was the
product where  you think to yourself
ah yes, of course Germany definitely needs
sports because of sports, they would probably have
needed bicycles or
but especially with the success in
the USA and so on,
you really have to say California
or the USA and even more specifically
California has made Porsche really big
in this respect  Maybe it was
the right one, so I have to say it
was definitely the right
decision and but he was an engineer.
Your father, I read, I
think he even
did an apprenticeship as a locksmith. So he also has a certain skill
Also tech
somewhere and then economics
studied economics but like that so
classically to become an engineer that was
never like that now people just
do that and then you can
too and then you understand the engines
and so on, well that's it of course  also
the reason in 1972 my
family or the family
withdrew from active roles in the
company
with the main aim of pursuing the same goal
and that there are no
longer any conflicts, so to speak, about who is now
taking which positions and
I think that has also happened  Approved in the ME in the
end we are now pursuing
the same goal as a unit, i.e.
making the company big but
not working on it operationally, that's how it is
and that was in 1972
and in that respect it was
never that issue for me, hey you
will one day be operational or will
one day actually
work as a day-to-day job in Stuttgart, yes
and I also found it important for me
as a person to somehow do my own thing
and yes, you know what
suits you and what doesn't and and I
I think above all that the creative
part, I definitely wanted to
accommodate it somehow in mine but so
engines came and these things that I'm
not that interested in as a fan, yes,
I think so, I can of course tell you
what kind of engines are in which cars
and  So as a fan, definitely,
but I couldn't repair the one in you
if you
want to be honest, so if you give me a
broken 356, unfortunately I ca
n't put it back together again, but do
n't you
worry a little bit  So I'm still a
bit under the agreement because I've been
reading Elon Musk's biography in the last few weeks and the guy is just
a badass engineer
himself and in the end
every car brand in the world is now competing with Tesla whether they want to or
not  Tesla so say that
stands out and also makes sports cars and
somehow makes SUVs and you do
n't think of yourself as someone who is attached to this
company somewhere, [ __ ], here comes
a guy who is just such an
over-engineer and he's also of a
reasonable age so he can  Do
everything yourself,
yes, worry so don't worry, no, but I think
that Elon Musk has
definitely created something that's mega, that's mega
awesome. In the end, he has the
topic of electromobility,
so it has disrupted it so much that
electromobility has become unavoidable
is because he proved, hey, it
works and then everyone had to
follow suit, but I think that has
now happened and
that, above all, the VW Group
is definitely well positioned
when it comes to electric cars, but you
also have to say  There are
still difficulties for customers, so the early
adopters are all already
on board with electric cars, so to speak, but
now I think everyone has
brand preme more cars to
sell, it's
probably also due to the current
market situation, but I'm worried
Definitely not, um, well, we're
not afraid of
other manufacturers, they've
definitely achieved something great, but we can
also
build cars, which I've also
seen on Instagram from you, the question
always comes up  your currently
your favorite vehicle so in everyday life
I drive a Taycan i.e. the
electric car from Porsche I also think it is
so I really like it I like
driving electric because it's
you it's quiet it's comfortable I
think it looks extremely cool
you  I can actually drive like a
combustion engine so it doesn't have the issue
that you or you can adjust that
when you take your foot off the accelerator that it
doesn't recuperate directly but
that it actually drives
like a normal
car
and I think  So it just
looks great, it's a great, great K. We'll
get to that in a moment. You're also
a bit of a racer.
Um, not really. Unfortunately, I can
actually blame my father
for not putting me in the
kart when I was three  Because
in hindsight I would actually have been up for it,
okay, but you can also
see that in your research I saw a few pictures like that, so you're
driving, it wasn't racing in the sense
of Formula 1 or something like that, but something of a
different kind  about racing, I say yes,
I don't have it, I
started later, so to speak, when I
was somehow in my teens, I
said okay, I'll let's
go karting at the weekend and so on, so
that started at some point
but way too late  Since a
professional career comes out of it, there is
no chance no chance, so especially if
you want to drive Formula 1 then you have to
sit in the kart as a 3 4 5 year old with no idea otherwise you have no
chance okay it's not just catching up in the
end vi me  My parents
also understand that, especially when my parents
were younger,
it was still a dangerous
sport, but back then it was really
dangerous. Every two races,
someone died in
Formula 1 and so on, me  I understand
that they don't say, of course, my son
should definitely drive Formula 1, how
are you 30 today and so we've
just talked about the
previous generation, so to speak, but it's
really giving up in
your generation now, or slightly, so to speak  Before
that, slightly after that, um, really, really
big family, so I had problems
keeping everyone apart and
also people who are sometimes in completely
different areas. I have
cousin K, who even has his own
car brand from the same tribe,
but there are also
I've read about those who are committed to Waldorf schools who are
taking artistic paths,
so there are very colorful, normal
families, no, I think so what, yes, I
think you could say that if we did
n't have this company that
somehow holds us together and keeps giving us that
which belongs to all of us in common
then I think
as a normal family, so to speak, you
probably wouldn't have any contact with
your great cousins ​​at all and so that has
its advantages, but I think especially in
our generation
I really have a few
friends in my
family too  and I think that we
all get along great, of course we have a lot in
common, just the
history and family,
everyone is with you. Um, yes, I was
with Ms. Bultra frer
Henkel Dynasty a few weeks ago and she told me about
it  have a family intranet and
also publish a family magazine
to keep everyone together a little bit and
somehow still have
communication between everyone and and
somehow we're not that big
so we can all still
meet up in a normal way, okay, we know
because you know  At the end of the day, it's
transparent to you at all, I do
n't have to say it, but I couldn't
determine exactly how much of the
entire group belongs to you. That
somehow has to be broken down to the people's heads,
but that's okay,
so that means that since we're talking, you know
exactly that, okay  And that's my
share of companies, to be honest,
I do
n't look at it that closely, so I don't have it
available now and I know exactly what
percentage
is mine, but basically you can get
through it relatively easily
In the end, we're not that big now
and at the moment your father is, so to speak,
the one who represents the family
and all gramien power exchanges
a lot with me so it's at the dinner table
or tells you a lot about it or is that a
topic between you  In any case,
it's always been
like that, to be honest, so of course it's
kind of an issue at the dinner table,
I'll say now of course we do
n't live together anymore, which means a little
less like that in everyday life, but as a family we have
family days where we meet where we meet
regularly  meet and talk about
everything that concerns cars and
companies and exchanges and then
of course there are the
congratulations to the individuals and if you are
of course in the same
supervisory wheel then of course you also have the
opportunity to exchange ideas but that's true
you're in a year  or for two years
now I think I've
also been a board member or committee member after
member of the Porsche design group,
yes, of the Porsche Lifestyle group, well
known to me as Porsche,
okay, yes, there are basically both things
under it, so the licenses and
Porsche Design as a brand mm  And
that makes sense because
this world of architecture has also made you a
bit of a designer, so at
least I take it from a distance, that's what
we've just
talked about on Instagram. Um, design is a
bit your thing, but you also have
you in a way  involved in the architectural office in
Vienna, um okay, so maybe for the
first part, I definitely
thought it was a cool combo, I had that or I think that above all my
understanding of design but also brand and so on
fits in extremely well and I'm
really excited about it  There
's a company that my uncle
built up and he's extremely
in love with detail and there's a lot of
historical and cool designs that
can be developed further and I
think it's a great opportunity in the end
because of course it's all consumer  facing
and I think there is a big brand, yes, it
's a brand in itself,
so I think it definitely has
a brand value, but it's
not as huge as you
might think, so it's
still a small, fine one  Forge,
so to speak, with the studio in cell and in
and in Ludwigsburg near Stuttgart what
are the main products that Porsche
Design currently sells I think
the coolest things are definitely
timepieces is a big topic
so watches which have always been strong is
sunglasses luggage is always  well, so
a lot of what is of course also
accompanying the vehicle but it goes up to
some clothes, so
to speak, across the board, so to speak, and that's a little bit now, so
not now operationally, but there is
your baby where you now
look at it as a board member, so to speak, and say okay  I'm getting used
to larger structures a bit, so it's
really exciting because of course you
have all the areas in there and
the advisory board itself is also exciting, which
means there are people in there with
whom you somehow get along with  you can exchange things
because you can learn something from them, who else
is in there other than your father, for example,
my father isn't in there at all, for example
MKE is in there already
here in the
podcast, and
then there's my uncle, my cousin,
Oliver  Porsche is my
oldest cousin, so to speak, so it's a
cool group, it's a cool group, so okay and
then tell me the architectural office, how did
that come about? To be honest,
that was still in my bachelor's degree that
we started
working together with Flo
I founded it with Oberschneider, who
said differently, he was actually already
self-employed, had his own office
and we met during the
internship at Porsche Design, he was
freelancing there, so I did an internship there in the
summer, um, and he
freelanced there and  Then we
became friends, we knew each other
from before somehow, our parents
are friends from Cell, um, and then at
some point later I had an
assignment on the line and then I
said, I'm too young, I do
n't quite have the courage to do it yet  alone,
I was still in my bachelor's degree and what
should you build? It was a renovation
of the restaurant or an extension,
or rather an extension, and now I did
n't trust myself to do it alone and then I
asked him if he was interested in
doing it together  and then it went
well and um yes
a year later we said
let's
start it together and
yes now there are 12 of us and it's
actually going quite well and we have
really cool projects in Germany in the USA in Austria
You D also acquire them or they so that means
projects in the USA you first have to
move to land like say now Viennese
architectural office so not just him
too but I think we have really
cool ones so of course that's a
start-up time you have to have something that's ready first
that someone even gives you an order,
so to speak, of course we
also do competitions, but
we still have the majority of existing
customers, so word of mouth, but
also just direct acquisition. I
mean, we now have a really
cool portfolio that you can show off  can
now almost do it by itself that was the
biggest say project Biss have done
so the biggest one in terms of area
is what we have just
completed, funnily enough,
handed over last week
and it is a
pulmonary specialist's practice outside of
Salzburg with two apartments upstairs  about it mhm
okay okay that's the biggest one and
that was the smallest one was a bar in Vienna
okay
or maybe even a bathroom but that
was a long time ago okay and that's
okay for your attention then
60 70% to do that yes we are now
unfortunately not in the same
office again at the moment we were in the
same office for a while so fat and
and F is if you look at the
podcast now then you can see you
are wearing a fat international sweater
the W is now the third area that
I am now focusing on  allude to say the
family and Porsche Design be at and that
the third so fat fat fat yes so that
's the company that has now emerged from the ICE
Race, so to speak, that was
I might have to start again one further
one further back so
but I  I think the structure is
your three big ones, these are the
three things that I
deal with and then I still have a
bit of a private life, but these are
the three things that
take up the majority of my time and there
is an iisrac right there  For decades
you have to say no, the
ice racing existed in Zell from the
50s, so in 52 it started until 73
and I had that I did
n't know anything about it, yes, that was for so long
in the past that that  not like
that anymore, so I think local people from Zell
already knew that, but my
generation had kind of
forgotten about it a bit. Yes, my
father bought a car that was used in the old
ice races and that came with
the old studded tires and that  There were
really centimeter-sized nails in it
and you drive on the lake,
so it was a car race on the lake with
skiers behind, so the pictures
are wild and so I
kind of fell in there. I then
asked him why
then he told me the story
and I just
thought back then, I started it with a friend
and I
thought ours was D so actually
that would be exactly what could somehow inspire the
next
generation  on the
motorsport not so much on Split
seconds but rather the whole
social thing around it that just looked really
cool visually, um and so to speak, rather than
building up a visual festival for the next generation
and that was the start of the ice racing that we
had  Then we just
started asking the
mayor at the tourism association
whether it would be possible at all to
revive it
and then we
did that in 2019 for the first time and how many
people are at risk, um  Around
130 went along and we had
10,000 people over the weekend. WoW is
already a real business
straight away, um yes, that was definitely
a
big number, of course, at the
beginning you somehow had investments in the
location and
so on  the lake that means the lake has to be closed no
the lake no longer freezes like that the lake
no longer freezes so much every 5 se
years or so that's at the airport it
would also no longer be possible at the lake I do
n't think it would be
approved  get okay so at the
airport in Zell am See there is
a small sports airfield
and that is our location
we have Hermann the ice cream master with
hands like that and every time
it is cold enough he drives the tractor
over there over an airfield and
Our route is given to us and then
everyone can take a ride, so you can just
register, you can, I just have to register, tell
us a little bit about the story about your
car and we'll see that we can somehow put together the
coolest and
most diverse group of cars
and that it is visually
appealing, that it looks good, the
right structure, no, not at all, brands
open, I always found it important because
in reality, I think I live
like this, so car cultcher lives, I think, because
you can say like this, your
car is cooler than yours  because it
can do this and that and I think it
thrives on the fact that you somehow
have this exchange and that it is open and
if you just reduce it to one brand I
think it takes
away the coolness a bit and but
in the end that's what it's all about  Really winning the thing
or is it more fun for
everyone, a bit like a
classic car race or how you have to
imagine, no, people are already
keen to win it, okay and then you have to
drive different elimination races for several days and something like that
So we first do qualifying and then there is
a mass start at the end
with four with the four fastest and
we do that across the six
different classes we have and
pretty much the same thing on both days and on the
last day on Sunday we have
it easy now  rebuilt now it's
just one day and then at the end you drive
a big
deciding race and whoever is the
fastest takes you with you, so
there's a winner for each class and the
business model in the end is that
people pay the participation fees so to speak to be able to take part
the B
model is sponsorship and
ticket fees so those are the two
revenue stream ticketgeb means there are
grandstands at the airport then
people sit and just pay for it
that S that we are building right we
have two old hangers there so two
hangers from the glider airfield we  are on the
glider airfield part, we'll
completely build them out, you'll have a bar
in there and we'll really build it
up so that it's a really cool
experience and everything looks cool
and you
somehow have it all together in a visually appealing way and in the end
it's there  yes a social event yes so people
come there because they meet new people
because they have fun because
it looks cool in the end
the snow flies in your face from the car
that drives past so yes okay but
then it's probably
like that you don't take anything  For participation,
everyone can register
and then you don't have to
pay €100,000 to be able to take
part, so participation
is basically three tickets, so
in the end you have to get three
tickets for yours  Participation for
mechanic friends etc depending on how you
want to use it and so you can
take part. We're doing two next year,
we're doing one in Asen in the USA and
one in Zellomse oh wow yes, you have to
say there's a relatively large
community of people now  So also all
over the world who somehow saw it and wanted
to be there, how did you
manage it? You asked me before
about influencers and
Instagram and so on, it was really all just that,
so it was really a natural
growth in the beginning  We
posted the old videos, we
told a bit about what was happening
and the first year of course
made a difference. Now you have to
say that then came two years of covid, which
of course gave us a bit of
time to rethink and say okay
how how  Let's carry on now, we
have something that people are up for,
that works, we have cool
sponsors at the start, so how do we
expand it further and that's where
the idea of ​​fat was born,
so it's an old one, fat is an old
one  old logistics company
actually stands for francais Alm
Transit now it just stands for fat
and we just have what they have
lemont cars sponsored two
winning vehicles 94 and 97 but also on a
wide variety of brands so not just
Porsche but also clean and Ferrari
and Co and us  We were looking for something
that embodies a bit of the ethos and
the vibe and the spirit of the ICE R
and we secured the IP of it,
so from this so the
former French-German
logistics company, if I understand correctly
and I just think the brand is cool and I'm
buying it  I mean, they were
really active in motorsports, they
sponsored all sorts of cars, they
became imor twice. You could buy the brand,
yes, that's really cool,
so you can buy an
established brand that's advertised so blatantly
for little money  It's
already a great exceptional situation,
especially if you have the whole story
that you have
if you go to Goodb now
or or any big
car festivals in the world then there are
Fettutos like H
found the brand everywhere  So how do you think that
anyone else could have come up with that,
that's already a brand like that,
it's already worth it, so I know the
story of Monclair,
the guy bought the old clothing brand, he's
now doing completely new things, but he's
become a billion-dollar company  we
thought so okay we have the
ice races we are really on to
something we then have a community
that is up for it so how awake how do
we grow with it where where is where is
potential Dr how can we
get rid of that too  only a one-time
event a year how do we do something in the
summer then we had the idea of ​​our
first location and
of course we thought about the brand, okay
what are there actually two
options: either you find
something of your own or you look for something
with heritage and see what  There is such a thing
and we looked at all sorts of things,
but at some point relatively
quickly we
came up with the idea of ​​going through the Porsche leem
victories and seeing who
sponsored them and who was still there
and who might be  no longer exists
and then we stumbled across Fett
and then you looked who owns the
brand e and then you don't have anyone else you
can simply register it mh and
the logo and so on, you can just
adopt that so I mean that's it now
or have you  of
course we redesigned it a bit but
it's still the same and
we secured the IP of it and
relaunched it okay and now the
core product is now the race
but not only that we actually have
three verticals at Fat  We used to have
events not only the
race, but also
track days on the Manka in our
location, a wide variety of events.
We have
just spoken, we have the
location with the mankeai on the Großglockner,
the Großglockner is like that  is the highest
mountain in Austria with a really
cool road up and down there.
My grandpa used to test cars there too,
so that means there's a
story
behind it and there was a hut for
sale and then we didn't
think about it that long, to be
honest, because  that somehow
seemed like the perfect match so
we opened the first location and we are now
looking for the
next one, it also
says international, which means no longer just in Austria
or ideally also in other
markets um and so that is the second
vertical  and the third is
products, i.e. streetwear or our
collaborations that we do, for example with
Porsche Design, so
being a clothing designer for them is also
a bit of an idea. Well, it's not
just me, to be honest, because I
think I know that  from
my architecture studies you have to do
a little bit, you can see that
relatively quickly someone can do something or
someone can't do something and I think I
know that I'm not a clothing designer,
that means we do it with a
team, I'm there, I'm on board with it but
I think what's always very important
with Fett is that we
really
go into detail in terms of quality and and I do that with
architecture, but I need help
with clothes, for example. I'll definitely take
help with that  with that
because I think it would be presumptuous to
say that I can do that without having
learned that and and say with the
locations so you just
described that that that the the place there on the Glock
what happens there is a hotel then or
is it  a small inn with two
rooms, i.e. a five-room and a
double room,
um, and we have now opened the first season.
Last May was the opening,
um, we completely rebuilt it with
the architectural office, um, and is
actually an inn, which means it is
a meeting place for  People who go over there,
the Groß Glockner is the
second most visited tourist attraction in
Austria, which means there's really something going on
there, there are a million people a year
who drive over there, um, and of course
it's a destination for people who
somehow go on trips,
go on road trips  um and we wanted to we wanted to
offer something we have
a community that is passionate about cars
the roadtps power and in the end we
now have the first touch for fat
where we can really do our own events
where we
can do events with our partners but where  also
simply where we give our
community the space
to organize something ourselves and to say hey, let's
go to mankeai on Saturday and
that started quite well or
started quite well in the first year okay
and so that's what that means for you  the future
is first of all an
architectural office then developing fat
to see what kind of Kabus can do
you come up with new
watch ideas new designs i.e. from hoodies
to, if in doubt, sunglasses yes with
FAT we want to be a bit the
Supreme for K yes I don't think that's cool
to define it so blatantly and to
say that we do exactly that, but rather to
leave it open a little bit and to let the
community have a say
and to always
bring in an element of surprise and
thus open up a world for our for our
customers or our community
from the location  from an event
to products and I think that
's the goal of Fett,
not to let it be boxed in by any conventions,
but to
really open up such a world,
you have the whole story of
suprema like that  In my opinion, I follow them, they come
from skateboarding and so on, and
then they managed to become such a
global brand
over a long period of time, of course,
but what I think they did so super cool
is that they never really did it that blatantly
they
never said okay, we're just that they
really arose out of passion
and out of their little
scene and then
got bigger and bigger um and I think
that's a really cool role model, so what
else could it be?  what what W in
your dreams what else could it
stand now next to events and next to let's
say clothes what else could
so locations is a topic that
interests me a lot because I can of
course also connect it with architecture
so I mean you have it open like that  a
touch for such
upscale new products, be it
events, clothes, watches, um,
that's a bit like that, a
bit like that,
the SAG the Austro German version of
Ronny
feig, yes, I don't know, I
grew up myself somehow our
summer holidays  For example, we were always
associated with some Porsche
parade somewhere in the
world. I grew up close to all the
enthusiasm surrounding the brand
and of course I
became a fan of it myself at some point,
so I mean I know
all this crazy collector  There are also what's the
name of this Magnus Magnus Walker
Magus Walker like this guys who drive like that
but also Jerry Seinfeld and so on
really cool people and they
sometimes have hundreds of them somewhere
and the whole WE don't have
parking garages that belong to them  full
of cars, yes, the scene around
Porsche is already really
big and and cool because it
sticks together super super and you actually
have a topic to talk about, yes,
and in the end it's one, it's one that
the brand lives from  Also, and I
always found that cool about Porsche, also um,
somehow as a child because I
noticed that there
was always a very strong cohesion and
actually always and a real
community and um that was also very inclusive,
so you  It's relatively easy to get in,
you actually have to, you do
n't have to have one, yes, um, so as long as you want to be able to have a say
and have fun with it, you go
to a meeting like that and have about
100 new friends, and
I always thought that was cool, yes  that Porsche
is somehow a luxury and of course a
high-quality product but at the same time
approachable and
somehow a passion for so
many people, yes and that's
really all around the world, I mean
Magnus Walker, who was also
OMR many times ago  Years ago he's been
on the road ne Jerry Seinfeld you
met Jerry Seinfeld I met Jerry Seinfeld
for the first time this summer, funnily enough,
how did that come about there
's a big event in Monterey
in California called Rennsport
Reunion which is the biggest Porsche
festival in the USA and there  He was too and that's
where we met. It's
actually a gift for the brand,
or is it organized by the brand,
but I thought it was
decentralized, decentralized, no,
I think that's kind of the
cool thing about Porsche  Porsche builds cars
because they believe that or because we
believe that they are the best things
that can be built and in the end there is
the world around that
sees that and understands that and
in the end that is the car
is the focus and that is also the case with
Fett, for example, the car is the focus
or is the centerpiece but the party
and the surroundings bring the le Dr so
what makes it really cool are
the people around it but yes so
whoever you are  Now you look at the company and look at
the value creation, then of course it's
cool that there are people all over the world
who are around your products
without you having to do anything yourself. They somehow
organize community events that
Jerry Seinfeld comes to, so I mean
which Mark has it where  Well,
someone in California says it's an
event now and then there are
stars and in the end you all benefit
because you're the one who
produces the product for it, so to speak, so I
think that's
the cool thing about it  There is
a community around it and an
enthusiasm and um in the end
people tell their own Porsche
story yes and make it their
own and um figures into the
Porsche universe somehow with it yes and
you grew up there, what was the
most absurd thing that happened to you  So in
all the years where you say okay what the
[ __ ] um yeah the first parade in the USA
was kind of crazy um the
Porsche Club USA is the largest um of
all the Porsche Clubs, I think there are
over 100,000 members in there who
really use toothbrushes  cleaning their cars
before the actual
day of the event and then setting it all up nicely
somehow and so the
enthusiasm around it is
already crazy so the craziest thing was
that
the craziest thing was that someone said
whether I or someone asked me
whether I was on their  Car and it was
n't now it was a he
can I sign on his car ultra ultra special car and
now you have to be honest I
may have the same last name but I
have I wasn't born yet when
the thing was built so I  I
really have nothing to do with the 19er
and yes, I think that's the
kind of moment where you kind of check
how much people are into the brand
and think the world around it is cool,
how do you see Formula
1 Formula 1 was at
Historically speaking, or family-wise, it
happened every Sunday for us. I
grew up with Schumi against Alonso
and Formula 1 was
always a thing every Sunday. Yes, you have to say that
as a child I always thought it was a
cool moment because you were somehow like that
Sitting in front of the TV with the whole family
and it somehow had something like that,
you had a
little brother, a little
brother and two older
half-siblings, so I did
n't grow up in the same house with them
because they were already
adults  So when this
Formula 1 topic happened, they
were already out of the house
m yes, I thought it was always such an
integral part of the
weekend and then afterwards we went
back out into the garden to play football and stuff like that, but
Formula 1 is like that  as or I was always
somehow a big fan of it, I think
what Formula 1 has achieved tremendously in
recent years is
through the Netflix series and since
Liberty Media took over Formula 1,
they have managed to ensure that the level of
commitment has increased extremely
via social media via the Netflix series
they have brought in a whole new generation
who are even more
deeply involved in the rabbit hole, who
really
know who which driver can work with which,
what they stand for, who knows the structures
in the teams and therefore what they have  They
've managed to make you really
part of this world and yes, I'm a
big Formula 1 fan, but what's
Porsche's plan? I've always had
rumors or is there now a final
statement about actually
a new engine for 2026?  There are new
engines, there are new regulations, these are
always the best times to
get into Formula 1. There
was a thought at Porsche about
Audi going into Formula 1 from
2026, which Audi is, you have to
say, a great one here  Brand
so it's far too short here our
long time partner Audi i.e. I FE mega
brand they are also with the E
ice racing partner I think that goes well
with the whole rally heritage
they actually invented the all-wheel drive
more or less and there's that
too  both in the past
and currently really cool cool
cars but to get back to Formula 1
yes they will be there from 2026 and have cleanly
taken over the racing team that is
currently driving under Alfa Romeo um
and yes and Porsche but has thought about it
but is not doing it  At the end of a Porsche
stood now there is no there is no
plan there but you would
probably like it if it did I
think Formula 1 is a great great
state so in the end I can't
decide so but uh Formula
1 is a great one  Great platform in
any case, yes, um, because it
appeals to a new generation because it
is so engaging and because it
is everywhere in the world and just like
we just talked about Seinfeld and Co,
every Formula 1 race
is like that  who always represent the elite of
actors, athletes, etc.
On the other hand, you
may not necessarily need it
if you're already a Porsche
and have this community and whether you
still need a Formula 1, so it
's also incredibly expensive  To take
part in it, Porsche doesn't have a
huge history with Formula 1,
although it has been there every now and then or
twice,
yes as a brand itself, so I
think if you now depend on how
you can judge it, of course you can say
more is more and there's a new one
Addressing the customer group certainly makes
sense now you have to say if
Porsche goes into Formula 1 then
you actually have to win then you have to
at least be a part of it, yes and that's
not so easy in Formula 1 it's
a huge deal
and a big investment is necessary and
Especially since the budget cap, Formula
1 has also become a business case, which
means that Formula 1 is no longer a brand, it is no
longer a marketing expense, but it
already has it. So Formula 1 is definitely exciting, yes, when you hear that, how deep are you now  If you
're involved in these questions, do you
also talk to Oliver Blume or the LZ
MKE, the person in
charge of the operations? If I have the chance,
I'll definitely ask them about
something like that, but you meet them sometimes
or there are events where you meet like that  It's
totally okay and it's clear to you
or that you will somehow inherit your father
in the role of supervisory body
one day or
is it, can it be like that or can it be clarified
what is the latter so it
can be like that but I believe in it  At the end,
I'm just focusing on my
topics because I think that makes the
most
sense, I have a lot to do, I
enjoy it, so I know my way around and
now it's not, it's not, yes, definitely,
but there's no clear order
Now, so to speak, that I am my father's
legacy because I am his son, but
in the end it is somehow decided by the family
as a whole and who
is most suitable for which positions. I definitely have
a passion for it,
I have an interest in it and
maybe he will give himself up  There will be something at some point,
yes, but I say there are
other family members who are
significantly less interested in it than
you are, so I mean you are, when you
hear all that, you're really
up for it, no, so I
don't think you can do that  I would say that there are already a lot of
us who are keen on cars and who
know their stuff and who
have been to racetracks a lot and so
maybe I'm into ice racing and all
about architecture and simply because I
grew up in the Instagram world, maybe a little bit
more present than some, but I do
n't think you can generalize how we
came to watch development,
so I mean, I immediately
noticed that I was a recent expert, so you or
even Instagram, to be honest, you
design there or fat also design
watches in collaboration  with Porsche
Design yes, so when the ice edge
started we thought about
okay what what what there is for natural fits
with with partners and one one a topic
that is always heard on the race track
is timing and Porsche the Porsche
design studio is 400 m  from the
race track so really a stone's throw
from our event location
I had already done an internship there
and of course it somehow has
the family heritage too and actually
Porsche Design really
started my fable for watches yes I
did have a fancy one for my confirmation  I
got the watch but to be
honest I never put it on because I
somehow had the feeling that as a
16 year old or something like that you do
n't wear a fancy watch, yes that
means it somehow
moved to the side and my father
got the first one in 1972  Chrono 1 came out, that was
the first black watch back then, so it was
really a world first
and there was a 25 year edition
when I was 4 years old and
my father bought it for my brother
and for me he put it in a safe and for
us at some point  When I was 17 or 18 I think I
got it as a birthday present and the watch ended up on my wrist because I had the feeling that a
I had a family connection
to it B I thought the cool thing about the watch was
that people who knew what they were doing
recognized it  So there's also a huge
following of them who recognize exactly what
that is, but it's like an if you
don't know you don't know kind of thing
so not now there's no
Rolex where everyone knows immediately ah yes that
's it  that's that and um I thought the
weight was cool I thought it was
somehow it triggered something in me
and then it really
started as if it started for me that I
wore a watch every day um and
yes like so many rabbit holes  Once you
fall into it and then
somehow deal with the topic behind it and
what the design is
and what the technology is and what
historical references there are
to it and so on, then at some point you always fall
deeper into it and now just in the
product universe  what my grandfather
started doing, what my uncle started working on
and designing watches with FAT and now,
for example, making the first military one with a little
manka on it, which of
course makes me really excited, which means they
asked you too, he you said
man, I have  Somehow a
kind of community has been created here around fer I
would like to do a collaboration
with Porschedesign and then make
everything clear, go ahead and
get started. In the first year the
partnership was of course even smaller,
but we had good ones  Arguments
there were 10,000 people because we had mega
pictures then sold so many collaboration watches,
we now have 50 of the very first ones
and then 250 okay so
the costs I asked you before
were like 10,000 € or so  No, yes, the first one
was a bit cheaper. Now
we have added a new material,
i.e. titanium
titankabit is even more scratch
resistant and
somehow significantly more resistant and
lighter than titanium, so it's like a
titanium on steroids  and that now ends up
at just over 10,000
€ since 2014, his own manufacture
again so they are really
watches built by hand in Switzerland and
of course that has its price and they
are now somehow FAT and Porsche
Design collaboration so okay okay and
what do you believe  You can get there in terms of pieces,
where can you get there, so if you
continue with that, right now the
capacity limit of the manufactory is
honestly the
sticking point, yes, there are now
just under 5000 watches, um, and I
think it's cool too  If it
stays a bit in smaller quantities and if
it's something special, it's less about
making a profit and
more about the brand but of course
making a profit of course making a profit is logical but I think
if you want to build the brand then
Do you have to approach it slowly and steadily?
I think if you
suddenly build twice as
many watches, then
of course you lose a bit of it. So
you also want your buyer to
be engaged and say, oh, cool, look
at that  There are only 250 of them and
I think it's important to let it
grow slowly but steadily
instead of
going full speed ahead, so now you are,
so to speak, the new generation W
talking about design and about the
brand world in today's world
Generation I'm now coming up with a
few other things that somehow
belong to the generation.
I wanted to talk about it, so how do
you see Luisa Neubauer, for example, who
if she
were to hear it all here now would probably say what are
these guys talking about?  Organizing races
at the airport is what
[ __ ] and it does
n't make any sense at all and there are completely different
tasks that our or your
generation has to do now than
something like that, how do you look at it? Well, we're talking
about fat  a very pragmatic
approach to it so everything that we
can do better where we
can establish improvements at the event itself that's what
we do and I think what's really
important is to get away from
the topic so it's just about
burning burning burning but
rather saying  hey it's about the
social character it's about
exchange it's about somehow being
inspired by the design and
technology of all the old things and
in the end if we manage to get the
next generation or young people
excited about technology then we have  something
has been achieved, yes, and then I think we have
a positive impact. I have to
say, individual mobility will
remain and in the end it is or is
the task, I think, to make it as sustainable
and positive as possible
and I don't think we are there at all
so far apart then of course
she won't say she's up for
car racing, um, but yes, I think in the
end it's about
inspiring you, um, making a new
individual mobility as
sustainable as possible, so that's what
you're already trying to do  the race
but the driving is also combustion engine
is not yes but also electric cars
okay so our most competitive class
is electric skiing so with
skiers at the back um so we are definitely
open to technology
and um I that's completely us too that
's us  Also very important is yes,
so to speak, we have a we
also have a relatively young customer base,
so to speak at is
Race. Because we
built everything up via Instagram and Core,
we of course also somehow attracted a whole new
target group with it
and I think  Especially with them it's
not like I said, it's not just about
burning somehow and
somehow so [ __ ] you Greta
stickers, we don't want to have Greta stickers at the event,
but on the contrary, we actually want
people who say hey, you can
somehow learn something from it, you can get
inspired  So the end of it
is the hope that you will win people over
to a technology who are then
able to make these technologies better, to
make them more modern, exactly and
the social context around it, okay,
but I still think it is sustainable,
first of all, that is not what it is
Obviously, that's clear, so you have to
say now, of course, that
motorsport in general
has a big task there, yes, I mean, no matter
what big events you look at,
the really big footprint is always
the people who come, that is, a
Bundesliga matchday, for example  then x
You say there is
no solution as such, but at least you are
still very aware of the whole issue,
100% and everything we
can do better at the event, so to speak,
we do so we no longer have
generators, for example, but do it
all via the Traffo  that we built,
we have a river, we
built a water pipe from the river to
make the ice so that we don't
deduct it from the drinking water and so on
and so forth, that then seeps away again,
so everything that we can implement,
but we're already doing that  You're
absolutely right, so I think
ideally we'll grow so quickly
that we'll be
able to show or present a relevant solution at some point,
but for
something like the viewers who
make a pilgrimage somewhere, it will always be, it'll never be
special  I think you
always have to do that somehow
under the topic of leisure activity, bringing people
together, there is
still a certain amount of freedom, so to speak, to
go to events and
sporting events in general, I
saw on Instagram, I kind of
tried to be Z a little bit Kim
Kardashian always wears Porsche Design
Sunglasses
I'm aware of that, yes, and how does that come
about? That's a good question, the
first, the first FA Shield sunglasses,
which Yoko Ono always
wore a lot and I think they also
made the glasses a bit famous
is a cool design piece and Kim
Kardashian has it on not only the
other but also everything naturally
arose naturally, just like Jerry,
it's quite helpful when
people are really known for
voluntarily always saying that, I
think  that's the above-mentioned influencer is the
biggest has the biggest reach there's
mega that she wears the product and and
carries it outside and and that makes it out of an
honest out of the honest out out of an
honest out of an honest love
for it you actually read a lot of
analyst reports
annual financial statements of  from say Porsche
or VW or something like that you look at it
so we don't W you read like that how does
the stock market now see the company so that we go
through it and then somehow comes from
I don't know JP Morgan cell or a buy
or something like that you look at yes that  I'll definitely take
a look, of course, I'll take a
closer look at
the companies where I'm on the bike, so
now at the PLX or or at the
Porsche Holding in Salzburg, which
does all the sales in Eastern Europe and in
South America and also parts of Germany and
France, so of course I look
more closely there because that's
my job, but of course
you also look at what the
market has to say about it, and what are the
biggest threats from your point of view, especially
for the company  W say that's where the company has to be
most careful, so I think the
entire automotive industry is faced with the
responsibility or the
challenge of making personal mobility
sustainable and I think
the biggest challenge that everyone is seeing right now
is that the market  is not yet
really ready for
electromobility in many respects and
that the customer
is still a bit hesitant,
so I already said the
early adopters and so on, they all
did it straight away. Now of course there is
a more complex market situation
I think that's a
challenge that all companies are
seeing right now. Do you sometimes wonder
about the Tesla
share price, no, because I think it does
really good
marketing, of course,
you wonder a little bit about the
market about the price
At the end of the day, Tesla is still a
small, small company that builds a
few more cars than Porsche but
significantly fewer than VW, for example, etc. But I
really believe that it has a lot to do with
him as a person and that people
trust him to do one  He
has foresight and he proves that with
his excursions into the
world, etc., of course,
have you met the staff? No,
I recently met Tesla's chief designer,
ah also with
German names, yes, Franz von
Holshhausen, but  he doesn't speak but he does
n't speak German but exactly who
speaks plays a big role in
the biography so book and he must have
contributed a lot to the success last year
so I think he's a very close
confidant of if you  Book trusts
at least yes yes, funnily enough, I was
with him in Pele Beach that's such a
conkour de legance so one also a
car an autosow where where it's mainly about
design and elegance and just over the
whole pre-war period right up to the
60s and 70s  Years is the latest thing that's
out there and we were honorary
judges together and he was basically
divided into small teams and
he was the song in our small team
and it was really cool to exchange ideas with him
and talk about one
cybertruck and stuff and I
asked him why it
all still looks so strange and
why they haven't gotten it right yet
that the car really
looks so beautiful and monolithic, so
in the end it's not that easy to
build cars but  I think it was cool
to talk to him and also to
point out things like that about all the old cars and
say, okay, that's a detail
he was excited about, but obviously he definitely
knows his stuff and
lived Tesla mas than me  I'm talking now in
my knowledge it's always this book W
isacson so if you haven't read it read
it, it really becomes
clear who all the leutenans
and so on the second level around Elon Musk
are and that's where he really is
because of that  I
just chose the German name and it
stuck with me
that he really played a big role
and he didn't just
do design but then he
also took on other jobs, I
read that it was just a startup,
relatively speaking  quickly became very big but
but of course there are narrow spaces
around it, yes the Irishman often
slept there in this in the first factory
and so yes I have to read through it so
the book is there for a long time
600 pages is really a  Great thing, I
've read it before,
but things
like that stick with you. Yes, speaking of the book, I
also wanted to ask about another book that has
really,
somehow, been with me for many decades now.
I once
read it in German kururs, buddenbroxs,
do you know that?  no really
notag Thomas Mann budenbrock it's
a business family
from Lübeck that is described there
where different
generations are traced, the
first one somehow created it and
made it big and then at some point we passed
into the third generation
no one who is very artistic,
such a son, and then is not
able to handle the competitive pressure of this
business and then
the company disintegrates and then
somewhere so TR g that I'm already in
the fourth year, yes, exactly, but I
thought like that  It's crazy when you read this
book, it
was standard in our German class. I
read it again afterwards and
since this book I've actually had a
general paranoia that somehow
even when I or always ask me when
I meet people who are like that  Roll
slipped in like you, what do you think,
you also have a new one, that Iras
could go wrong, that you might
not see something D such a company
can also be gone quickly but okay if you
don't know the book then but I do
n't have that  a paranoia because in the
end I think it's all
teamwork and both in our
family and in the company I think
we're real so it's just a
team effort in the end and I think when
you're aware of what you can do  and where
your strengths are and what you don't
do so well, I think you
always somehow find the
perfect team composition, so to speak,
and I think that's a skillset
that we now have as a family
that we
stick together and  that we speak with one
voice and that we
choose who will fill which position
or what do you have planned for the next
few years so is an ECE RCE in
Espen I have now when is that on
February 8th to 10th okay we just have
them  looked at the markets and said
okay where where are we growing with fat
in which direction do we want to go and
of course we have Europe or Central Europe
of course with zellamse and Manke and
so on and so on, um and of course I've been
in the USA a lot
recently  We looked at it on the
way there and there's
just a crazy car culture and
people are really crazy about it
and it's just a huge market in general
and then we
looked at it as we went in there and
said it's great  It makes most sense to
go in first with our Halo event and then maybe with
a location in the second step
and we came across Espen relatively quickly,
of course the ski resort is
somehow bad
but it also has a race track right
next to it so a few points ticked right away that
we  somehow we
wanted you to, you don't have to persuade anyone to
come to EN, I think
everyone is already there anyway and eV is
on the racetrack then first we close the
cutting edge and then we ice it
lightly, we'll start things off
small  in quotation marks so there
are now 600 people then at the start a
total of spectators only 600 yes in total
only what costs
ticket the smallest ticket costs 00 that
yes we looked at what
everything in Espen is generally expensive in Espen
honestly how much does the
ticket cost in  in
89 yes there is a difference but you have to
honestly say Aspen is simply
different so first you have to do a lot there
so of course you have much higher
costs because everything in the USA is
three times as expensive anyway and Espen is
then again three times as expensive  as USA
and W Zell is a general admission
ticket and in Espen we have
a hospitality and food and beverage
all inclusive and two days and
evening event and so on and immediately so what
you get is
a little bit but is management
If you sell it out then
immediately at the first event it will be
profitable, as I said, with the
sponsor together with the sponsor, these are
the two
sources of income then you can also make
a profit or earn money with it.
Yes, I believe that we
earn money with it  Fat already money
and with Asen we are just about
a black zero now for the
first event yes the brand is going
alone so or are you saying 100%er
yes okay so the Heß the company is driving is
yours and the funding for it, so to speak
You then take the projects,
so to speak, from the dividends or from
your from your reserves, yes, that
's how it is, of course we have it
in the first year now or it's
already 5 years old, so to speak, if
you also drive forward with the time
ICE added to that and so on, of course, the
two covid
years were a
great success and then came the
two covid years, which were of course an
event, I don't know, you
probably experienced it too, absolutely, we
were of course still there in the winter
Really full throttle lockdown in
Austria too, of course it was
n't as we
hoped it would be but but yes I take that
from my so that's what I have now how
many people are working fat in the
core team we are four people and
Of course, the event itself is growing
hugely with external service providers and
the like and for the individual events
we still have agencies that
do the whole onside management, so to speak, and we have to
do it first with a lot of
people, so an ICE RCE in Espen is
already the word yes  Definitely relatively, yes, well,
we also have an agency
with us, you have to say now, but yes,
we are definitely still very lenient,
which I also think is cool
because in the end we are
somehow quick-witted and able to work
with others quickly  Orientate the direction
but we definitely need now we are
growing now definitely yes that
means me if you get something like that now big
and a fat is great in terms of lifestyle, say if
it succeeds,
say a global car lover brand like that  Being able to
flange like that is
actually almost more charming than
having to work at Porsche somehow. I wouldn't say I
think working at Porsche is very
cool, yes, fat
is definitely the result of a passion,
yes the first ice race was
now  Admittedly, in the first
step I didn't think of it as a pure business model,
but of course somehow a matter of
the heart and I thought to myself
hey cool, now I'm just about at the
end of my
bachelor's degree, so that's kind of what
I'm still doing,
I'll start writing my master's thesis
now  At some point I
moved it to Iceway, but
architecture was also in Vienna because
I was somehow already located there with the architectural office and the like,
which means that it would
n't have made sense
to go somewhere else and yes, that by the way  I've
done it for the last two years
and now
I've given myself a break, so to speak, and now I'm doing
Malin after the ice race, I
'm off to work on my master's thesis. So I
have a very big sympathy for people
who do an event by chance
and then suddenly notice it  There's
a company there somehow, so it does
n't seem completely unknown to me and yes, I'm
keeping my fingers crossed,
I'll
probably take a look at Instagram now,
follow a little bit what you're doing,
you definitely have to come, exactly
when is on January 27th, okay  Okay, it's
already sold out but maybe
we can get a ticket for you but
like just behind the car that has to be
hard fix let's
go I did that once
I did that once and I
tore my biceps tendon okay wow because of
that  It's hard, so it's hanging, it
was that classic water skiing
accident, so I was the rope wasn't taut
at that moment and the car
accelerated and I wasn't far enough
away, but it's generally dangerous too,
so at least I imagine if
you or are all the races like that where a
sheer hanging behind the car yes where no the the the
class so the sheer in class
there are two once so the spirit of the
ice in terms where it's really about
having a kind of funny outfit at the back and where it is now  Not really about
that, so of course there's also timing but
that's really more of a spirit and
the coolest
combo of car and
skier wins and then the electroskiering
where it's really about time and in
skiering we don't have a
mass start so in skiering  Are they
far enough apart that nothing
can happen? Okay, okay, but as I said, yes,
my biceps weren't big
enough. I at least always do pull-ups
and try but that we don't
hold either, so thank you very much for
coming around and
yes, totally interesting to hear  How
you design it for yourself, so to speak,
and which path you choose is really
not easy in some way, so
of course you have a great job, but I
can also imagine that it
's definitely challenging in some way,
sometimes I say a certain amount of burden, so that
's probably it  A bit of both,
yes, I think you just have to
do what you enjoy.
Funnily enough, that's what my parents always
said, so yes, you have to find a job that
you enjoy, then you'll be good at it
and in the end I think I've
found something  I'm in the mood and your
father is also having fun, his job is
also right so Kage Heß he no, my
dad is definitely a big
KAG too, yes, what's it like now my dad is 80
but then maybe at some point it will be
The question is what
happens next? Yes, there is already
a succession plan in which he has
already said that my eldest cousin
Oliver will be his successor, my
dad is definitely
more into cars when he
was young  So, for example, now really if you
go to the cars that he's really
passionate about or something like that, his
favorite car is from the time
he was young is the 356 but it also drives a
Taykanan, for example  So it comes from eisracege of
course, really, hopefully he'll drive
at 80 too, but he can still
drive a car well, all clear, thank you very much, all clear,
all clear ciao ciao
[music]
ciao